eyeos elle vient tout juste d'être sorti
de façon officielle on parle plus de la
bêta on parle de la version vous pouvez
vous téléchargez d'ailleurs si vous avez
un iphone vous pouvez faire la mise à
jour vous avez vraiment venir faire
parce qu'il ya plein de paramètres à
venir activé directement pour utiliser
parfaitement bien son iphone et surtout
pour avoir un maximum de sécurité g15
réglages à vous donner à faire on y va
c'est parti
on va commencer directement et s'ils
venaient voir au niveau de la
confidentialité et de la sécurité ça se
passe juste là on va commencer par le
menu suivi dans le suivi autoriser les
demandes de suivi des apps autoriser les
apps à vous demander la permission de
suivre votre activité dans les
applications ce qui va se passer c'est
que lorsque vous l'aurez autorisez vous
allez avoir toute une liste
d'applications et voir les applications
qui vous suivent comme ça vous avez un
oeil vous pouvez désactiver à tout
moment et vous êtes quand même
relativement peinard autre truc super
intéressant il faut que vous veniez
juste ici tout en bas tout en bas tout
en bas dans le rapport de
confidentialité des apps faut vraiment
venir l'activé alors le rapporte
confidentialité des api l'extrême moins
importante à ce que vous allez voir
quelles sont les applications qui vous
suivent enregistrement des données accès
à vos capteurs activités en ligne bref
vous saurez tout venez l'activé alors
moi j'avais désactivé mais une fois que
vous l'aurez active et vous aurez une
liste complète de toutes les
applications qui viennent vous suivrez
vous saurez exactement ce qui se passe
sur votre iphone comme ça après vous
pourrez venir désactiver l'accès à
certaines apps vous maîtrisez votre
confidentialité et ça c'est quand même
super important on revient ensuite sur
son menu général et on va dans
notification alors là une nouveauté sur
ios est ce qui est vachement bien c'est
la façon où on venir sa fille chez vos
notifications vous avez trois paramètres
possibles alors moi je vous montre ma
notification sur ios est salée
notification arrive par honda ça c'est
très chouette ça change un peu et ça
évite surtout de l'avoir directement sur
le haut ce que ça venait bouffer votre
heure comme ça vous avez vos
notifications qui sont juste en bas
alors voyez hop là j'en ai deux j'ai mon
train dans quelques heures faut que je
me dépêche et puis j'ai à
l'enregistrement de l'écran qui vient de
s'arrêter parce que j'ai switché et je
suis venu ici grâce à ayo et 16 on peut
bien choisir la façon dont vont
s'afficher les notifications sur votre
iphone si vous choisissez nombre vous
allez juste à voir le nombre de
notifications si vous choisissez pile
vous aurez toutes les notifications en
un seul et même endroit où cliquer
dessus ça déroule vous êtes penarol en
liste vous allez avoir toutes vos
notifications les unes au dessus des
autres ça prendra plus de place moi je
préfère pid moi y'a un truc qui m'embête
très souvent avec mon iphone lorsque
chez en train de passer un coup de fil
et j'appuie sur mon bouton et bien ça
raccroche ça ça fait péter un plomb donc
on peut venir désactivé je montre
comment il faut faire vous venez d'en
accessibilité vous allez ensuite d'en
toucher ici et vous descendez chercher
ne pas raccrocher aux verrouillages ce
qui fait que lorsque vous allez appuyer
sur le bouton sur le côté sale n'a pas
raccroché et ça va éviter de couper les
conversations ça c'est quand même relou
autre paramètre important concernant
syrie vous venez une fois de plus dans
accessibilité et vous venez chercher
juste en bas ici syrie et vous venez
activé en bas le paramètre annoncé les
notifications sur le haut-parleur et
ensuite vous voulez choisir les
applications a notifié vous pouvez
choisir de mettre sur les écouteurs
d'encarts plaît annoncer les nouveaux
messages ne pas annoncer nouveau message
mémoriser le réglage précédent bon
annoncer les nouveaux messages et
ensuite vous choisissez les applications
qui vont pouvoir énoncer les
notifications comme ça vous maîtrisez
les applications importantes pour vous
font ça très bien très pratique parce
que lorsqu'on a les mêmes prix si par
exemple j'en sais rien moi vous avez
carte planes est en train de conduire eh
bien on va pas y accorder ces
notifications c'est beaucoup trop
dangereux on va laisser ses rives où les
énoncés et ça c'est très bien autres
réglages qui paraît vachement important
concerne les notes alors vous venez au
plat et vous cherchez vos notes regarder
elles sont situées juste ici vous venez
chercher ensuite mot de passe ici et là
vous choisissez cote de l'appareil
jusqu'à présent vous pouvez venir
verrouiller une note mais avec un autre
passe donc si vous aviez plein de notes
et plein de mots de passe différents
c'est quand même relativement le bordel
là vous mettez cote de l'appareil et
même failli dit comme ça si vous avez
une note de verrouiller vous voulez la
déverrouiller posé vers gré avec faith
heidi ou alors avec un code unique ça
c'est quand même vachement rassurant
eyeos 16 apporté son lot de nouveautés
notamment concernant safari et j'ai noté
deux réglages important bien faire ici
alors vous voulez fatalement dans safari
dans safari vous venez tout en bas ici
vous avez un onglet réglage des sites
web partagé entre les appareils se
permettra de partager le réglage d'un
site web entre tous les appareils que
vous allez pouvoir avoir que soit votre
mac soit votre iphone soit votre ipad
c'est extrêmement pratique venez cochez
cette case là autre astuce très
importante à connaître ici au niveau de
safari vous venez ici dans
confidentialité et sécurité et vous
venez masqué lippé alors vous avez le
choix entre tracker les sites web
tracker uniquement ou le désactiver je
vous conseille de laisser activé pour
les traqueurs et sites web ça empêchera
aux différents sites web ou différents
tracker qui cherche alors des
informations sur vous une pas connaître
votre adresse ip de ne pas connaître
votre localisation et ça va venir
vraiment protéger vos données
personnelles avec ayo est ce qu'un je
crois que sérieux s15 est arrivé le mode
concentration est là cette fois ci le
mode concentration va encore plus loin
alors je vais vous montrer comment ça
marche vous venez ici bien évidemment
dans votre mode concentration vous venez
ensuite danse tu concentration et vous
allez choisir ici qu'est le mode de
concentration vous allez partager avec
les contacts autorisés moi par exemple
j'ai fait le choix de partager ne pas
déranger repos et travail repos c'est le
soir on dérange pas je suis chez moi le
travail je bosse on ne dérange pas et
puis à ne pas déranger je veux pas qu'on
dérange raconte j'ai pas envie qu'on
sache quand je fais de la méditation ou
quand je prends du temps pour moi
notamment comme ça c'est jamais votre
boss de vous rejoindre dans la journée
et que vous êtes en séance de méditation
il ne saura pas vous êtes en séance de
méditation vous pouvez lui dire non
j'étais en train de bosser c'est tout
pas compliqué bien ça je vous parlais
syria deux paramètres abda voir ici qui
sont super important pour siri vous
venez d'en syrie et recherche et vous
allez dans raccrocher les appelle ici
vous venez active et ça ça c'est
vachement bien une fois de plus lorsque
vous êtes en mobilité en train de vous
déplacer pourquoi imaginez vous êtes en
voiture vous avez car play ou votre
smartphone qui est posée sur un côté et
vous téléphoner avec les hauts parleurs
de la voiture pas des écouteurs pas la
main ça c'est dangereux on le fait pas
et vous voulez raccrocher sauf que vos
mains sur le volant et vous n'allez pas
bien toucher votre téléphone vous dit
juste dit raccrocher comme sa scierie va
venir raccrocher la conversation
directement et vous vous avez les mains
libres vous êtes en toute sécurité autre
paramètre qui me paraît quand même
plutôt pas mal vous venez ici dans
l'envoi automatique des messages vous
savez lorsque vous avez vos écouteurs et
que vous dicter un message cyril à vous
demander envoyer le message a alors si
vous voulez pas passer par cette phase
la plus que sa part directement vous
cochez cette case comme ça cyril enverra
directement sans vous demander une
confirmation d'envoi ça pourra venir
s'appliquer à vos écouteurs ou à carpes
l'oeil c'est à dire tous les moments où
vous n'aurez pas votre smartphone dans
la main vous c'est quand même vachement
pratique autre paramètre qui me paraît
vachement important au niveau des mails
notamment au niveau du délai d'envoi je
sais pas si ça vous arrive et vous êtes
en train de taper un email et vous
faites pas exprès vous envoyer les mails
y paraît merde on peut pas l'arrêter
alors il existe certains logiciels
certaines solutions où on peut venir un
nul et ça on ne pouvait jusqu'à présent
pas le faire dans mail et enfin apple
est venu corriger ce problème très
simple vous venez ici dans mail et vous
allez tout en bas dans délai
d'annulation l'envoi et là vous
choisissez un délai soit pas de délai je
ne conseille pas de faire ça soit 10
secondes ce qui est quand même déjà pas
mal vingt secondes ou trente secondes ça
dépend de vous si vous êtes extrêmement
précautionneux pourront à 10 secondes ça
ira bien vous verrez déjà s'il email est
en train de partir vous l'annulez
pouvait continuer à le taper modifié
l'éditer et ça c'est très rassurant
vraiment je vous l'assuré il ya un autre
élément qui est extrêmement importante
dans mail c'est la confidentialité vous
venez d'en protection de la
confidentialité et vous venez activer sa
protégée votre activité dans mail comme
ça mais elle va venir cacher votre
adresse ip on connaîtra pas votre
localisation ça va venir protéger et
éviter que vous soyez traqué par des
emails non désiré là il y en a aussi un
paquet là les autres astuces et pas des
moindres on arrive à la fin vous venez
ici dans son et vibrations une nouveauté
t'arrivait caillou et 16 au niveau du
retour clavier vous venez ici vous avez
le choix lorsque vous tapez sur votre
clavier d'avoir soit le petit bruit tac
tac tac tac tac d'entendre ce qui se
passe à la place de ce à quoi je n'ai
pas particulièrement ce truc n'est
réellement je coupe et où je tapais
j'avais pas d'un oui bon ça m'allait
bien et maintenant ils sont venus
activer leur tour par vibration c'est à
dire que c'est un retour haptique
lorsque vous allez venir tapez sur votre
clavier vous allez sentir un petit
retour sur votre doigt voyez lorsque tu
en train de taper ici je sens quelque
chose sous mon doigt il doit vous
assurer qu'au début ça paraît un peu
bizarre d'avoir ce petit truc là sous
l'eau on dit c'est quand même c'est quoi
ce truc est en fait on s'habitue très
bien et on a un vrai retour on sent à
quel moment on est en train de taper et
chaussures franchement canal et un
dernier paramètre à connaître ici dans
son et vibrations qui vient de faire son
apparition dont le commutateur sonnerie
silence vous pouvez choisir lorsque vous
switchez voyez sur le côté d'avoir des
vibrations lorsque vous êtes en
haute-saône riz ou en mode silence alors
moi ce que je vous conseille se mettre
uniquement les vibrations en mode
silence et le téléphone va vibrer sans
vote à vous serez alerté puisque en mode
sonnerie hilson vous êtes déjà alerté
donc a pas besoin de rajouter des
vibrations par dessus donc ce que j'ai
fait moi j'ai désactivé les vibrations
en mode sonneries et j'ai activé les
vibrations en mode silence ça paraît
logique alors je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez dites le moi on va dans les
commentaires voilà pour ces quelques
nouveautés à connaître ici à soyaux est
16 alors il y en a d'autres des
nouveautés ainsi vous avez déjà installé
à ios est ce vous avez vu que vous avez
notamment une petite recherche en bas
des nouveaux fonds d'écran bref il y
aurait 16 apporte son lot de nouveautés
ça c'était les paramètres qui me semble
être important en termes de
confidentialité en terme d'expérience
sur son smartphone si vous avez d'autres
astuces pour les marquer juste en bas
dans les commentaires et plus donnant
rendez-vous très bientôt pour continuer
à parler de teck bien évidemment d'apple
mais pas que je vous embrasse à bientôt
ciao
[Musique]